[Música]
hace dos años china alertó a la
organización mundial de la salud sobre
una neumonía viral que luego sería
reconocida como kobe 19 el director del
organismo dice que las variantes del
tallo micro amd crean un tsunami de
positivos
en llamada telefónica los presidentes de
eeuu y rusia hablarán este jueves de la
creciente tensión en ucrania joe biden
estará preocupado por la presencia de
tropas rusas en la zona limítrofe y
vladimir putin exige garantías de
seguridad a occidente
en hong kong cientos de policías
allanaron el medio online prodemocracia
stand news seis personas fueron
arrestadas por conspiración para hacer
publicaciones sediciosas esta es la
página más destacada de las que aún
critican la china continental
hola bienvenidos a esta actualización de
noticias en francés 24 los saluda daniel
hablando iniciamos hablando de kobe de
19 porque se cumplen dos años desde que
en 2019 en la víspera del año nuevo
china alertó a la organización mundial
de la salud sobre una veintena de casos
de una extraña neumonía que luego sería
el hobbit 19 dos años después el
director del organismo asegura que la
circulación simultánea de las variantes
delta y omicron está creando un tsunami
de casos
mientras la mayor parte del planeta
celebraba el fin del 2019 una nueva
amenaza de energía el 31 de diciembre de
2019 china alertó a la organización
mundial de la salud de 27 casos de una
neumonía viral de origen desconocido
identificados en la ciudad de wuhan lo
que semanas más tarde sería catalogado
como el zarco 2 virus que produce el
kobe 19 oficialmente el primer caso de
la gripe de buján fuera de china se
registró en tailandia el 13 de enero de
2020 y rápidamente se extendió por todo
el mundo
el desarrollo y distribución de una
vacuna dividió la opinión pública siendo
la o ms principal promotor de la
inoculación pese a que más de 9 mil
millones de dosis se han administrado
mundialmente en un año las autoridades
sanitarias se lamentan no haber
alcanzado las metas propuestas alcohol
on leaders of reach can risk and
manufacturers hago un llamado a los
líderes de cada país ya los fabricantes
para que aprendan las lecciones de alfa
beta gamma delta y ahora omicron y
trabajen juntos para alcanzar el 70 por
ciento de cobertura de vacunación de
cesc de time este es el momento de
levantarse del cortoplacismo y proteger
a las poblaciones y las economías contra
futuras variantes game future trends con
la llegada de omicron y cumpliéndose el
segundo aniversario desde la aparición
del cob y de países como francia estados
unidos e india registran cifras récord
de contagios aunque no de muerte sobre
sus lluvias enzo pérez me decirle a los
que no se han vacunado hay pocas
posibilidades de que puedan escapar esta
vez el virus se está extendiendo con
demasiada fuerza y los más propensos a
contraer el virus y desarrollar formas
sintomáticas y graves son los que no se
han vacunado una vez que las mascarillas
y el testeo ya son un denominador de
todo el mundo la oms se confía en que el
2022 ponga fin a la fase aguda de la
pandemia
y justamente francia es uno de los
países europeos que se ha visto más
golpeado por esta nueva ola de contagios
en la última jornada del país galo-
contabilizó 208 mil nuevos casos que
establecieron no solamente un nuevo
récord nacional sino europeo francia ha
estado batiendo récords continuamente en
los últimos días el ministro de salud
informó que cada segundo dos ciudadanos
son diagnosticados con el nuevo corona
virus actualmente los hospitales están
en límites preocupantes con ingresos por
la variante delta y también hay
expectativas sobre los efectos de la
recién descubierta o micro
cambiamos información porque en colombia
la corte constitucional ordenó restituir
los derechos a siete emigrantes
venezolanos que fueron expulsados
arbitrariamente del país según el alto
tribunal tras ser detenidos ilegalmente
por la policía su proceso se adelantó de
manera indebida por migración colombia
atentando contra su dignidad humana
durante el paro nacional de 2019 por eso
establecemos contacto con lucía ramírez
bolívar ella es coordinadora de
investigaciones sobre migración en la
ong de justicia lucia muchas gracias por
atendernos y le pregunto primero cómo se
logró esta victoria de derechos humanos
y cómo serán resarcidos los afectados
muy buenas tardes daniele gracias por la
invitación pues en este caso llega a la
corte porque estas siete personas con el
acompañamiento de la clínica jurídica de
la universidad de los andes presentaron
una tutela que fue negada en primera y
segunda instancia pero fue seleccionada
por la corte constitucional luego de
prueba que también se solicitará
formalmente que la seleccionará la corte
entonces revisó este caso y como tú
decías consideró que en el procedimiento
de expulsión se vulneraron las garantías
al debido proceso el derecho a la
dignidad humana y a la unidad familiar y
entonces le ordenó tomar medidas muy
concretas en este caso la primera de
ellas es que debe repetir el
procedimiento sancionatorio migratorio
es decir que la orden de expulsión queda
suspendida hasta que nuevamente se haga
el procedimiento con garantizando pues
que se para que se cumplan las medidas
del debido proceso que se tenga en
cuenta la situación particular de estas
siete personas y el impacto que una
decisión como ésta podría tener en la
unidad familiar y en los derechos de los
niños y niñas de los cuales estas
personas pues son responsables o que
habían dejado en colombia si una vez la
corte determina que no hay motivación
para haberse dado esta expulsión debe
revocar la decisión y además deberá
ofrecer disculpas públicas tanto la
policía como migración colombia a las
personas afectadas por esta vulneración
de derechos sin luz y ahí cree que éste
podría hacer una muestra más de la
creciente xenofobia contra los
ciudadanos venezolanos y además como se
combatiría este fenómeno creciente
definitivamente digamos a nosotros nos
preocupa mucho cómo se está utilizando
la medida de expulsión no solamente en
este caso sino en otros casos como lo
muestran cifras que hemos publicado en
nuestra página web
siempre digamos en el contexto tan
particular que sucedió este caso que fue
en el marco del paro nacional de 2019
donde se estaba buscando un chivo un
chivo expiatorio para justificar muchas
de las acciones que se estaban
presentando durante estos días nos
preocupa el mensaje que desde las
autoridades está dando al acusar a estas
personas de haber participado en los
disturbios de ese día sin tener las
pruebas suficientes y esto obviamente
incrementa los sentimientos de xenofobia
de la ciudadanía en general esperamos
que este fallo mande un mensaje muy
claro a la necesidad de que se
garanticen todas las medidas y el debido
proceso en estos procedimientos
sancionatorios migratorios pero además
también que se restablezca el derecho a
la honra y al buen nombre de estas siete
personas pues hoy lucía muchas gracias
por atendernos hablamos ahora de otros
temas porque este jueves los presidentes
de estados 2 joe biden y de rusia
vladimir putin sostendrán una llamada
telefónica para discutir entre otros
temas la creciente tensión en la
frontera con ucrania desde el gobierno
estadounidense señalan que byd en la
insistir a su homólogo ruso que la unión
americana está preparada para responder
ante una eventual invasión a territorio
ucraniano
en esa diplomacia con nuestros aliados y
socios europeos consultando y
coordinando un enfoque común en
respuesta a la concentración militar de
rusia en la frontera con ucrania
el presidente ballena ha hablado con
líderes de toda europa y los
funcionarios de la administración baiden
se han comprometido multilateralmente
con la otan la unión europea y la ocs
los funcionarios también han mantenido
numerosas consultas con sus homólogos
incluidos los de los países del flanco
oriental de forma bilateral y en el de 9
así como con ucrania y hong kong él
vivió una jornada de arrestos contra
miembros y ex miembros del medio de
comunicación pro democrático estándar
news cientos de policías allanaron la
sede del portal de noticias y los
domicilios de varios editores para
investigar la supuesta distribución de
material sedicioso
nuevamente las autoridades de hong kong
cargan contra un medio de comunicación
pro democrático unos 200 policías
allanaron la sede del diario están mls
para investigar un supuesto caso de
distribución de material servicios ohl y
detuvieron a seis miembros y ex miembros
del portal de noticias web entre ellos
al editor jefe en funciones patrick lahm
desde el medio sin embargo defienden su
trabajo
stand news está haciendo reportajes
profesionales no hay duda al respecto
todo el mundo lo ve no importa qué
cargos se hayan hecho nada puede cambiar
esto aunque ya está un auditor no han
calcado venido así son durante varias
horas las autoridades incautaron
numeroso material periodístico para
negar su línea de investigación apunta
hacia una supuesta violación de la
polémica ley de seguridad nacional por
parte del medio que en los últimos años
se ha mostrado como uno de los más
críticos contra la presencia cada vez
mayor de beijing en la política
hongkonesa
cualquiera que intenta hacer uso del
trabajo de los medios de comunicación
como herramienta para perseguir su
propósito político
intereses contraviene la ley hunter
pence trono parte canal y ofensas
particularmente los delitos que ponen en
riesgo la seguridad nacional son los
elementos malvados que dañan la libertad
de prensa that's timer transferida este
es un nuevo caso en el que se investiga
y detiene a miembros de un medio de
comunicación pro democrático de sant con
el cierre del periódico apple daily en
junio de este año marcó un antes y un
después en el ataque a la libertad de
prensa en la antigua colonia británica
a ustedes gracias por acompañarnos feliz
tarde
[Música]